make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are covering the Batman who
laughs part five and again like like the
Batman who laughs is solid I guess it's
one of the coolest things but in the in
the last video that we had the way we
kind of left off was that the Batman who
laughed essentially like tricked these
cops at Arkham Asylum into believing
that like the actual Batman was the
Batman who last and again this is kind
of a kind of a cool cool scheme because
what better way to make an escape then a
look at your current circumstance and
then finding out that way right like
it's the best way to do it each the art
of war by Sun Tzu right like don't fight
on their tour territory fight on your
territory use your skills against them
Batman undertook the the task of
becoming the Batman who laughs in order
to figure out a way to defeat him and in
doing so almost engineered his own
demise and this list this first bit of
the comic really picks up with him just
being like shot at by all these cops and
the Batman who lasts teleporting away
and Batman tries to reason with him but
but remember because he's sort of
turning into his evil counterpart what
this means is that this darker side is
beginning to take hold a little more
than it had before now as an internal
struggle that's constantly going on
between the two of them but the idea
here is he says okay look there's a part
of me that just wants to kill these guys
and be done with it but I can't he was
basically fleeing for his life now
because it suits Kevlar it makes it
almost impossible for them to basically
penetrate so then they start calling in
like armor-piercing rounds now here's a
kind of crazy thing here is the way this
is happening the way this is going down
it's kind of difficult for a Batman to
differentiate between what's actually
happening and what's not actually
happening because remember he's
basically you know using a mask of the
Batman who lasts he sees people's darker
intentions and he hears what he wants to
hear and so what this means is that he's
hearing them say things like shoot for
the mouth you know we can't we can't
penetrate his suit so just shoot him in
the mouth who's always made sense what I
did shoot Batman in the throat but the
question that's kind of being asked here
is are they really saying that or does
Batman believe they're saying that and
the implication is that it goes either
way from there Batman realizes the only
way to really make an escape is to
pretend to be the person they fear so
much and that's exactly what he does he
sits down he says okay fine
it's my only out here so he starts
running off the names in the addresses
and all the things that he knows about
these cops that are familiar to him and
basically says if you do not let me
leave here I will find you I will track
you down and I will kill everyone and
everyone you ever met like I'll kill you
and everybody that you ever met here and
it's cool because it scares them out of
their wits and he says I'm the Batman
who laughs follow me down if you want to
and then basically makes his escape and
that's kind of the cool thing here is we
Batman's not actually becoming the
Batman whoo laughs he's pretending but
it allows him to kind of tie into that
character it works both ways
if the Batman who laughs can use Bruce
Wayne as his own means of escape by
basically treating everybody to believe
in the Bruce Wayne is actually the
Batman who laughs then Bruce Wayne can
build on that use that to his own ends
it's one of the ways to show that Batman
is very quick on his feet but for here
of course it really kind of catches
Commissioner Gordon making his escape
this is one of the things that's kind of
interesting is because when it comes to
like the little Robins that the Batman
who last had at his disposal we never
really knew who they were or where they
were from what we're actually told here
is these are all different versions of
the son of Jim Gordon now in reality I
would probably say that this is kind of
Scott Snyder just throwing it out there
that there was never really any
intention to explain where they came
from so just kind of tied in to the
story in them to say well they're all
your versions of you know all the
versions of your son Jim Gordon from
like different places in the dark
multiverse but it's cool because it's a
way to torment Jim Gordon I remember
this is basically like The Punisher
Batman more or less whose people you can
call them whatever you want to you know
but like its Punisher Batman more or
less is really what it is but basically
it's him just kind of tormenting Jim
Gordon remember the vendetta between the
two is really only one-sided that in the
the university comes from the grim
Knight is basically a guy who was like
defeated by Jim Gordon he was a
vigilante Punisher Batman who was
eventually caught up to and defeated by
Jim Gordon and Jim Gordon's eyes he's
just kind of a kind of a crazy guy and a
maniac but in the grim Knights eyes is
hey like you you defeated me in your
universe so I'm gonna defeat you in
yours it's kind of a twisted sort of
scenario but again in the midst of all
this is Jim Gordon making his escape
he's caught up to by his son and
basically you know his son kind of helps
him get out of there and and you know
recover and so on but from here we
switch over back to the Batman who
laughs in one of the coolest parts of
the story because a question is asked
like why have you come here and it's
like well I came here because I wanted
to address you because I wanted to talk
to you because I have a small favor you
know and so on and so forth and it's
kind of kind of this disembodied voice
and as soon as I heard that as soon as I
saw that I was like okay he's talking to
the court of owls and that's exactly
what it is
it's one of the coolest things the
Batman who laughs meets the court of
owls and this is awesome because the
court of owls is like this really
clandestine organization that ran Gotham
behind the scenes we know that from
Scott Snyder's run on the new video to
Batman and it's so cool to see him kind
of rat back around than what here
we created and sort of tie it in to the
cons to the content going forward it's
awesome now the funny thing about this
is that the court of owls traditionally
allows the youngest member of the court
to choose what's going to happen to a
particular person who's either been
brought there or who has strayed into
the path of the owls and doesn't really
know what they're getting into and so
the youngest person basically comes out
you know you literally have the bat man
who laughed she says hey look you know
all I have is a small favorite lass
that's all I really have you know and
the youngest person says no no we're not
giving you anything we're gonna take you
out
and so what ends up happening is they
basically say like the talons are gonna
kill you now of course those of you guys
who are unfamiliar with the court of
owls the towns are basically their
henchmen they're the people they send
after you to either kill you or bring
you to the court or whatever the case is
but that's what the Batman who lasts
says but that's the thing though guys
like I've already talked to your talents
and I've removed their arms this is how
crazy that Batman who lasts is how
dangerous he is he gets in there and
says okay what's the most immediate
threat to me if I walk into where the
court of owls aren't okay well then the
most immediate threat is the talent but
Batman who lasts is not walking into
this blind and that's cool because what
he says is that in another universe in
the dark multiverse because of how
extreme you guys were and how crazy you
guys were there was a kind of respect
between yourself and like Bruce Wayne
and so in an alternate in a in a dark
multiverse there was a time when Bruce
Wayne took over the court of owls and he
became the head of the court the new
town and he controlled everything and so
like I'm well aware of who you guys are
I know what you guys are about you guys
are just rich folks you guys use talents
to do your bidding but while your talons
are gone what are you guys you're
nothing you're you guys are weak you
guys are you guys can't do anything on
your own
without people protecting you it's kind
of interesting and so of course this
leads directly to like the arrival of
this Batman from the dark multiverse who
took over the court of owls facing off
against like the Batman who laughs now
of course he's defeated pretty quickly
and so what we do is we switch back over
to Batman enter to Jim Gordon now the
cool thing about this is that remember
one of the big talking points here was
the last laugh program right like the
idea that basically this this could be
activated and initiated and it would cut
Gotham Gotham off from like the rest of
the world right like it would cut him
off or cut it off from the rest the
United States water electricity the
whole nine yards everything would be cut
off and Gotham would become a totally
self-contained ecosystem and Batman's
plan with Commissioner Gordon was to do
that was to activate the last laugh
program to cut Gotham off to make sure
that nothing that that man who last put
in the waterways could be expanded and
and basically extended out
into the rest of the country but that's
when Batman begins to think well that's
what the Batman who laughs wants it's
kind of crazy it's kinda like well but
what if this is what he wanted all along
what if what the Batman who last one and
all along was for gosselin to be closed
off was for Gotham to become its own
source of power for Gotham to be
isolated and removed from everything and
to become its own place but if he did
then the question is why and that's when
he gets a call from the Batman who
laughs and he's told do not answer that
call do not respond to that call where
he kind of takes his hand off the device
and says no no you know we we will we
will give it a minute or two you know
cuz you got a two-minute countdown right
like once one so the first hand is put
on there it takes a two hand system once
the first hand is put on there you've
got two minutes in order to activate the
whole thing and that's when he basically
says okay let's see where this goes
let's see what happens with this he's
talking about a man who lost the Batman
who laughs says you don't understand the
true basis behind Gotham now this is
kind of a cool thing there will be those
who will kind of look at that and say oh
man here we go again bad doesn't know
everything about Gotham whatever like
the cool thing about this is I love the
idea this Scott Schneider introduces
this idea that Batman doesn't know as
much about Gotham as he thinks he does
and that's what's so awesome is because
what it does is almost kind of paints
Batman in this light of being arrogant
did Batman you're not as smart as you
believe you are and that's what the
Batman who lasts basically says that the
way that Gotham was originally built the
way it was originally designed Gotham
was designed to be a seat of power the
Gotham was designed to be a city where
the person who ruled it could
essentially extend their influence out
to the rest of the world in a myriad of
different ways you could cut it off you
could shut it off from the rest of the
world and you could say like gossip is
totally isolated and alone and this is
awesome because again like it gives like
whoever it is it controls Gotham or who
is who's sitting on Gotham if this last
life program is operated will
essentially be able to like operate
outside of the United States and do
their own thing like you can poison the
rest of the world and Gotham will be
fine and that's kind of the cool thing
here is because one is up happening is
like Batman liz is literally being
talked to you by Jim Gordon and they're
saying like don't listen Alfred Alfred's
coming in offers chiming in don't listen
and Batman can't help but listen Batman
can't help but hear what's going on and
and what he ends up doing is actually
agreeing with the Batman who lasts that
many laughs says like press the button
put your hand cut Gotham off from the
rest of the world let Gotham be what
it's supposed to be let it be it's
darker side and Alfred is kind of crazy
Alfred chimes in for a second and says
hey look like you're not yes we'll see
this year you are the living heart of
Gotham
here's a guy that tries to make the city
a better place and baton has responses
and it hasn't worked he's not fixing
anything and so what what is up having
is like in the final moments of this
Batman puts his hand on the machine and
basically follows through with the plan
of the Batman who laughs and shuts down
the entire connection between Gotham and
everything else and so essentially
Batman has joined the Batman who last
and it's pretty awesome like it's it's
pretty solid but would that be said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you